hello there anime fans i hope you're
counting your fingers to the release
date of the fourth season
of everyone's favorite man vs monster
show so while we're waiting let's back
things up a little and take some history
lessons now shall we but don't worry
these aren't your regular history
lessons these are the info dumps that
made your jaw drop and think
honestly titans are the last thing i
should be worried about in this world to
keep things fair for my anime viewers i
won't be including any manga spoilers in
this video but do keep in mind this
video has spoilers for all
three seasons also don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to see
more awesome content like this since
there are a lot more top 10 anime
content coming your way with that said
here are 10 attack on titan plot reveals
that you never saw coming at number 10
we have aaron's titan revelation
at the end of the first arc things were
desperate not only for the new recruits
but the main trio as well erin was eaten
armin was psychologically fallen down
and mikasa was at the edge of giving up
and along comes a muscular force that
starts knocking off titans with his
punches this new titan seems to be the
soldier's ally
and possibly a force to be reckoned with
moments later it's revealed that inside
the nape of this beast
was aaron now this may be a surprise for
mukasa and all others but let's admit it
we saw this coming now didn't we i know
attack on titan got popular for killing
off characters and was dubbed as the
anime game of thrones but surely it
wouldn't be bold enough to kill off the
main character
even if he wasn't the best main
character have at that moment but
the twist showed that there were indeed
people who can transform into titans and
humanity had their own weapon to fight
off the threat of these giant beasts
next up at number nine we have the
revelation of the titans hiding inside
the walls
attack on titan's popular for two words
it's freedom
and the walls the two words aren't only
thematically related the latter is also
what protects the people from the titans
you can see the irony comes in here
in the very first episode of the second
season the face of a titan is shown
inside the walls this puts both the
survey corpse and the general populace
in panic was the thing that they feared
the most
actually what protected them at the same
time this is the first time
attack on titan poked a clue at us about
its law and showed the world has more
than what meets the eye
at least let's hope someone won't awaken
those colossal titans in the walls eh
coming in at number eight we have yemi's
transformation to a titan
what's with everyone transforming to a
titan when things turned desperate
first it was aaron then it was yamir and
then soon there's another duo in the
case of ymir she decides to pull the
blade and transform when the tower's
just about to collapse there were a lot
more candidates for titan
transformations and it was a surprise to
see yami being one she was always a
character who blended into the
background nicely and didn't get that
much attention but
it is attack on titan and even side
characters have a role to play in the
turn of events
ymir's titan came off as a surprise as
well while the previous titans were much
larger
yemi's titan seemed smaller and her size
seemed to be the exact thing that played
for her advantage
at number seven we've got the revelation
of the fake king
sometimes the show isn't all about
attacking titans the first court of
season three gave us a nice political
backstory mixed with some new characters
like kenny the ripper and rod reese it
also had some revelations in store for
us from royal families to character
pasts to political deceiving one thing
that belongs to the latter category is
the reveal that the white head old man
is just a puppet placed on the throne he
may have had an intriguing look of an
old king
but in truth it was rod reese who was
manipulating everyone in the background
of course the credit for the revelation
and the crude attack should go to the
one and only irwin smith because this
man managed to open the eyes of the
military once again
coming in at number six we've got the
revelation of annie leonhardt being the
female titan
in the middle of the second arc came the
threat of the female titan a titan more
athletically capable than other humans
and seemed to possess
intelligence similar to a normal human
after erwin's failed plans in the woods
all hopes seem to be lost then we're
directed to scenery inside the walls
where we're shown the daily life of a
depressed and anti-social annie
leonhardt
armin urges her to assist them to help
aaron escape and this
girl takes the bait surrounded by people
right at the top of the tunnel comes one
of the greatest revelations of attack on
titan
annie leonhardt was the cold and
ruthless female titan
well let me tell you this when the
apathetic girl suddenly gave unlike
yagami laugh and showed off her gamble
aaron wasn't the only one with the wide
eyes and surprised reaction
at number five we've got keith shaddis's
involvement with grisha jaeger
sometimes a bystander is more than a
bystander everyone was surprised when
keith mentioned aaron's mother back
during his training and the third season
shines the spotlight on this keith is
actually revealed to be a friend of
erin's father and it turns out grecia
wasn't the best friend someone should
have
keith explains the mysterious actions of
grisha after the fall of shiganshina and
finding eren in the forest this
explanation shines some light on the
scenes we saw in the second episode and
we begin to realize how aaron received
his titan form it also cast our
suspicions of grisha jaeger and we begin
to realize this man has a much bigger
role in the story
rather than just being the father of the
main character this is another example
of how even the minor characters of
attack on titan play a major role in the
events that happen and even though
characters might not realize it
themselves
they are more than just bystanders next
up we have the revelation of historia
who thought the cute girl that
alleviated everyone's stress would be
related to the royal family once again
the role of side characters comes into
play as we realize that crystal lens is
actually historia rhys a daughter born
to rodrice her past isn't the only thing
that's a surprise
along comes the revelation of a hideous
royal ceremony where children are
allowed to eat their predecessors to
gain the power of the mysterious
founding titan this is also where the
actions of eren's father comes into play
as we're shown how he forcefully took
the power of the founder
and passed it on to eren not the best
father then and then again rod can't
even be called a father to begin with
burdened by the fate of their parents
both aaron and historia are confused
about what to do
with the former urging historia to kill
him this revelation brought out the
theme of burden and for the first time
approached the history of the world in a
broader manner
coming in at number three we have the
first appearance of the female titan
now i know i already mentioned annie's
revelation but i'm sure the moment you
saw
a massive towering female standing up on
the isolated land beyond the wall gave
you the chills
up until that point we thought eren was
the only titan shifter
now imagine when a more athletic titan
comes and kills the soldiers one after
another leaving a trail of blood behind
either she was another titan shifter
like aaron
or anime's largest female psychopath
she also displays intelligence by
covering her nape when the survey corpse
fly behind her and then proceeds to take
them down in the most brutal way
possible credit should be given to the
directors and animators for portraying
this new threat in such a horrifying way
and showing us how dangerous the female
titan actually was the scenes that
preceded this were a mixture of
tension action and subtle creepiness
when the female titan lowered armin's
hood and gave that creepy smile i sure
thought that things were going to turn
upside down for levi and his gang
next at number two we have everyone's
favorite scene from attack on titan
the reveal of the armored and colossal
titan
after nearly three years this scene
still gives me the chills and it's no
wonder this was one of the biggest anime
reveals of all time
i watched with baited breath as the
so-called big brothers of the survey
corpse turned out to be the duo
that caused the destruction of
shiganshina five years ago it was like
the most climactic moment of a detective
anime where the culprits are revealed
and the conclusions about to come but
this time the climax happens with the
action and a bombastic sarwano
soundtrack and the conclusion is eren's
scream of rage
as he attacks the armored titan the
entire moment was like a perfectly
directed
four minutes jam-packed with revelation
and action and this scene managed to
prove the existence of multiple titan
shifters apart from just aaron yamir and
annie
reiner rarely broke down but when he did
he did it with a bang
topping our list we have the greatest
revelation of all time
the existence of people beyond the walls
[Music]
it's amazing how three diaries of a man
can turn your perspective
of 180. i'm not just speaking of life
beyond walls but
everything related to grecia's memories
including the war between
elder and mali the attack titan and even
minor revelations like the titan of dina
fritz
if attack on titan was a puzzle with
missing pieces this was what completed
it the man vs monster show
suddenly turned into a racist war
between men themselves the theme of
freedom no longer applied just to the
titans
but freedom from the wider world as well
it gave more depth to the story
expanded the world and even changed the
perspective of aaron and others it's
like you're trapped in a dark room and
given a torch to find the door
but after you open the door you find
yourself in a much larger and complex
mansion honestly i don't think even that
metaphor would be suitable for what
isayama has done to us
[Music]
so out of these 10 plot revelations
which one hit you the hardest we know
what hit eren the hardest and season
four
is gonna be proof of it speaking of
season four manga readers out there know
there's a lot in store for us that could
fill in another top 10 list so keep
counting down until december the 7th
that's it i hope you enjoyed the video
and don't forget to drop a like if you
did
that's it for today anime fans and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]